the Joe Rogan experience we do what we
do a teacher training a yoga training in
India every January I just got back from
it yeah I saw it on your Instagram it's
great it's super fun we do it we have
three academies we have a music school
where we study Indian music and kirtan
we have a 300 hour training for people
who are already teachers and we have a
sacred literature she studied the
Bhagavad Gita and all these sacred texts
we were talking about that before the
podcast I really wanted to get into that
eventually you know like the the the
mystical aspects of the Bhagavad Gita
and of the Mahabharat all the ancient
Indian texts which are filled with
really wild out there [ __ ]
you know I mean it's all real in what
way just like all the things that you
say like well that's interesting that's
fast fascinating that's just fantastic
the more you get into you me lies that's
freaking real like what look what's real
everything from like the vamanos vamanos
eye things like that I can't say a real
but I could I could understand how
things can be made of subtle energy
explained v monster if you man is like a
spaceship yes it's like it's a spaceship
from and they speak of spaceships and
flying crafts you know they're not made
of the same elements of this earth right
so we have all these things about you
know and I get it there's a bunch of
people making up [ __ ] about about I saw
an alien etc there's also very qualified
people you know Air Force Colonels and
things like that I said I've had them in
here you've had of it yeah they look at
it and they suffer from the same thing
these people of these who claim
abduction it's not like a type of
neurosis or schizophrenic stress since
yes like they something happened they
disappear they were found two weeks
later do you remember the story of Betty
and Barney Hill no it's the most famous
abduction story it was an interracial
couple from I think was the 1950s or the
1960s and just random my interviews
always go here I had this girl on the
podcast this woman on the podcast
yesterday she's an MMA fighter her name
was Angela Hill she's a couple days ago
actually this
badass MMA fighter and at the end of the
podcast goes I forgot to bring this up
my grandfather is Barney Hill and I was
like that guy I'm like no [ __ ] way
that guy Barney Hill was the very first
like really public UFO abductee and
there's ricourt and he it describes his
craft that's eerily similar to the
crafts that Bob Lazar is described and
different people described in he and his
wife lost time while they were driving
and then woke up with these bizarre
horrific memories that they both shared
of this encounter with these space
beings and that they were abducted and
they were medical examinations were run
on them then they were replaced with
missing time and it's crazy we listened
the recordings of him being hypnotized
and going through it like screaming and
fear that they're touching him and then
where they taking and what are they
doing to him it's not like a guy acting
it's not like a scene where a movie
where someone's screaming in fear it
sounds real and I just the teachings of
ancient India is that life exists on all
planets it even exists on the Sun and so
the first argument we like come on how
we gonna exist they just still have
bodies of different that are different
than yours I'd have a fire body and
therefore I'm trying to look at
everything how does a person with earth
and water body live in the Sun they
can't write you have to have a body I
mean I used to think like this when I
was 13 years old right I used to think
like okay why can't my dog hear those
sounds but I can't hear them right what
am I missing what's sense am I missing
that I can't have objective reality you
know what am I missing
am I missing a sense well I have this
this principle called the the fart
theory
like if someone farted but you didn't
have a nose you'd have no idea you'd
have no idea have no ID but oh god what
is that if art theory is the beginning
of trans identify yeah because it's
there's a sense that you possess that
allows you to access ya recognize
something that's invisible you can't see
it you can't feel it you can't hold it
there's nothing you you you don't
there's no way of detecting it other
you're all factory senses but through
your nose you can detect uh something's
awful what sense am I missing that's
keeping me from understanding absolute
reality sure I mean that's one of the
things that you feel when you take
psychedelics like this is opening up
some new sense that I was this around me
all the time I'm just not tuned into it
because I don't have the right chemical
composition flowing through my brain
when I start to teach a bigger training
like a yoga training and philosophy it's
one of the things I do mainly I start
with this concept that this is how you
understand like when I first approached
teachers when I went to India I would
say things like I'm reading this
Mahabharat I think it's a great book a
lot of great lessons here but come on
we're adults
am I supposed to understand that
a elephant-headed man scribed this
entire book
can't we just extract a a useful lesson
and the answer was very good that I got
was and it was very sweet
it wasn't like cruel he just said what
do you know I sorta like caught me off
guard like what do you actually know
right what do you know and I and use
this example you from New York okay
suppose 300 years ago you're living in
New York your family's living in New
York your tribe is living in New York
you have a certain amount of animals and
animals that you keep animals that you
ride animals that you hunt foods you eat
and then one of you goes on a boat to
Africa and you come back and you think
you're never going to believe what I saw
I saw a striped horse you're thinking
well I've seen striped horses white head
black neck no no no no I saw striped
horse if you've never seen a zebra it's
almost unbelievable if all you know is
ponies right or I saw this horse with a
really long neck that ate the leaves on
the trees come on man it's all fantastic
because we've never seen it right but
that doesn't mean it does so to really
understand the Vedas the teachings of
ancient India you have to go into it
like not that it's all real I'm not
saying to just blind faith but I'm not
saying don't be a blind doubter like
it's all unreal that's [ __ ] that's
crazy that's nuts
it's got to be could be I don't know but
I don't know a lot what do you think the
Elif what do you think like Ganesh was
Ganesh the being
[Applause]